>>> ARE YOU READY?
ARE YOU FEELING IT?
DO YOU HAVE HOT TAKES?
ARE YOU SITTING NEXT TO KING
JOSIAH?
NO, THAT'S JUST ME.
WELCOME TO "TAKE MASTERS," THE
ONLY SHOW THAT ALLOWS YOU TO
FIRE OFF HOT TAKES AND THEN GET
JUDGED BY TWO ESTEEMED TAKE
MASTERS.
I'M THE LEFKOE MAN.
YOU --
>> THE LEGEND.
I'M KING JOSIAH, I DON'T HAVE A
THING TO GO AFTER THAT.
>> JOSIAH THE MAN.
>> TURN UP.
>> SIX LETTERS.
>> I WANT Y'ALL OUT THERE TO
KNOW HE HAD NO PROMPTER.
HE COULD HAVE WENT OFF THE DOME
WITH THIS THING.
>> I JUST CAN'T READ.
THAT'S THE ISSUE HERE.
WELCOME TO "TAKE MASTERS."
HELLO TO EVERYBODY IN THE B/R
APP.
I HAVE THE B/R APP OPEN.
WE'RE LOOKING AT YOUR COMMENTS.
WE'RE JUDGING YOU.
MOST IMPORTANTLY WE'RE LOOKING
FOR HOT FIRE.
THIS IS THE AMERICAN IDOL OF
SPORTS TAKES.
DO YOU WATCH STEPHEN A. AND GET
ANNOYED?
THIS IS YOUR OPPORTUNITY TO FIRE
OFF TAKES.
WE'LL BE SHOWING A BUNCH OF
TAKES.
OUR BIG QUESTION TODAY IS WHO IS
THE MOST IMPORTANT PERSON IN THE
NBA PLAYOFFS?
WE DON'T WANT JOEL EMBIID.
WE DON'T WANT YOU TO SAY LUKA.
GIVE US A SAMPLE, NOT YOUR MAIN
TAKE, BUT A SAMPLE OF TAKES THAT
YOU'VE SEEN AND YOU GO I LIKE
THAT ONE.
>> WE KNOW THE MOST IMPORTANT
PERSON IS LeBRON RAYMOND JAMES
SR., HE'S NOT IN THE PLAYOFF, SO
THAT MEANS YOUR TEAM MAY HAVE A
CHANCE OF WINNING THE
CHAMPIONSHIP.
IF HE'S LURKING, YOU DON'T HAVE
THAT OPPORTUNITY.
>> I WAS GOING TO SAY THE PERSON
WHO TWEETS FOR MAGIC JOHNSON.
>> HIT'S NOT MAGIC?
>> MAGIC IS PRAACING AROUND IN S
OFFICE GOING TWEET THIS.
SEND TWEET.
THAT'S WHAT WE GOT GOING ON.
AS THE TAKES GET MADE, JOSIAH
MIGHT THROW IN A GIF, THEN WE'LL
REACT.
WE SEE YOU IN THE B/R APP.
THE SCORING THIS WEEK --
>> WE CHANGED IT UP.
>> WE'RE NOT DOING ONE THROUGH
TEN AND ALL THE SCORING.
WE'RE SIMPLY GIVING ONE OF TWO
REACTIONS, A GOOD REACTION AFTER
LAST NIGHT, A PAT BEVERLY SMILE.
JUST A HAPPY FACE.
PAT BEVERLY GOING OUT THERE,
TAKING HIS SHIRT OFF AND CRYING.
CAT KISSING HIS GIRLFRIEND,
FEELING GOOD.
IF WE DON'T LIKE THE TAKE, J
JAY-Z'S SCRUNCH FACE.
>> CAN WE TALK ABOUT THE
TIMBERWOLVES AND PAT BEV?
IT WAS A LITTLE TOO DRAMATIC
BEATING THE CLIPPERS.
>> SO GOOD.
>> JERSEY OFF.
>> CAN I TELL YOU, I WAS IN MY
HOTEL ROOM WATCHING THIS, I WAS
LIKE THIS IS INCREDIBLE.
"INSIDE THE NBA STARTED" CHUCK,
SHAQ AND KENNY STARTED ROASTING
THEM.
ERNIE WAS LIKE WOW, SHORTEST
SEASON EVER.
THAT'S WHY "INSIDE THE NBA" IS
INCREDIBLE.
WE'RE LIKE WOW, LOOK AT THIS
SCENE?
THEY'RE LIKE WHY ARE THEY
CELEBRATING SO HARD.
IT WAS FROM HIM CRYING TO
KARL-ANTHONY TOWNS KISSING.
>> LeBRON LAUGHING EMOJIS.
CONGRATS ON THE CHAMPIONSHIP.
IT'S GREAT TO SEE EVERYBODY WAS
LOCKED IN.
TIMBERWOLVES FANS, WE'RE NOT
TAKING AWAY FROM YOUR MOMENT.
WE WANT YOU TO ENJOY IT, BUT
YOU'RE WAY TOO TURNED UP FOR THE
SEVEN SEED.
I GET IT.
I'M IN A LeBRON LAKERS FAN, NOT
THE CHAMPIONSHIP.
>> I AGREE.
WHY ARE WE BEING SO SENSITIVE?
TAKE THESE JOKES.
YOU WON.
IF THERE'S A TIME TO TAKE THE
JOKES, THE WHOLE -- LET US ENJOY
THIS MOMENT WAS NONSENSE.
>> TIMBERWOLVES FANS, THIS IS
PART OF BEING ON TWITTER.
THIS IS WHAT WE DO.
WE THROW OUT JOKES, MEMES,
EVERYTHING.
PAT BEV WAS OUT THERE SUPER
TURNED UP, I RESPECT IT, NOW YOU
HAVE TO DEAL WITH THE MEMPHIS
GRIZZLIES WHO ALSO TALK TRASH.
>> THE FACT THAT THERE ARE
TWEETS OF PAT BEV COMING AT JA
MORANT, NOW THEY GET TO PLAY
EACH OTHER?
>> GREAT BASKETBALL.
I'M EXCITED TO SEE IT.
JA, GROWN MAN WITH TWISTIES AND
CUTTING THE EYEBROWS MAKES ME
NERVOUS, BUT HE'LL MAKE BUCKETS.
>> WE HAVE SIX TAKES THAT PEOPLE
HAVE SENT IN.
MY NOTE TO EVERYBODY WATCHING IN
THE B/R APP NOW, IF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO HAVE YOUR TAKE JUDGED ON
THE NEXT EPISODE OF "TAKE
MASTERS," WHEN WE PUT THIS OUT
ON TWITTER, WHEN WE PUT THIS OUT
ON IG, SEND IN A 20-SECOND
VIDEO, DM IT TO "BLEACHER
REPORT" ON THOSE TWO PLATFORMS,
YOU WILL HAVE A CHANCE.
OUR FIRST ONE TODAY, WE HAVE NOT
SEEN THEM.
WE DON'T EVEN REALLY KNOW WHAT
THEY'RE ABOUT.
LET'S SET IT UP.
THE FIRST "TAKE MASTERS"
SUBMISSION.
WHO DO WE GOT?
>> ALL RIGHT.
MOST IMPORTANT PERSON DURING THE
P
PLAYOFFS HAVE TO BE K.D.'S PR
MANAGER.
TAKE THE PHONE, THROW IT IN THE
SAFE, IN THE OCEAN, MAKE SURE
K.D. IS OFFLINE.
WE NEED HIM ON ZERO DARK 23 OR
WHATEVER LeBRON USED TO DO.
WE NEED K.D. SOLELY FOCUSED ON
GETTING BUCKETS INSTEAD OF W
WORWO
WORRYING ABOUT INTERNET DUDES.
>> HIS PICK FOR MOST IMPORTANT
PERSON IN THE NBA PLAYOFFS IS
K.D.'S PR MANAGER, SAYING HE
NEEDS TO BE FOCUSED.
I'LL GIVE MY THOUGHTS BEFORE I
GIVE MY SCORE.
MY FIST THOUGHT IS I LIKE THE
CREATIVITY.
I LIKE THE NOTION OF NOT TICKING
K.D., BUT HIS PR PERSON.
MY INITIAL REACTION IS I THINK
K.D.'S THERAPIST IS TWITTER.
I WORRY IF YOU TAKE HIS PHONE
AWAY AND HE KEEPS ALL OF THAT
INSIDE, I THINK IT'S LIKE A DAM.
YOU'RE BUILDING IT UP.
I THINK IT NEEDS TO GET OUT.
WHAT ARE YOUR INITIAL THOUGHTS
TO THIS?
>> CAN WE SHOW THE GIF I PULLED
FOR THIS MOMENT?
THAT WILL ENCAPSULATE EVERYTHING
I'M THINKING.
NOT A GOOD TAKE.
K.D. IS LITERALLY THE KING OF
TWITTER.
THE MAN NEEDS IT.
HE'S JUMPING ON SPACES WHILE
HE'S EATING FOODS IN BETWEEN
GAMES.
HE'S NOT MOISTURIZING HIS ANKLES
BECAUSE HE'S BUSY FIRING OFF
TWEETS.
LeBRON FAMOUS FOR CUTTING OFF
SOCIAL.
HAS NOT DONE MUCH THE PAST FEW
YEARS.
LeBRON WAS SOCIALLY ACTIVE LAST
NIGHT.
LET K.D. GET THE SLANDER IN.
IF HE WANTS MORE BURNER
ACCOUNTS, LET HIM BE.
I NEED TO SEE K.D. DOING IT,
GOING AT PEOPLE.
>> YOU JUST NAILED IT.
I'M GOING TO GIVE MY GRADE.
I'LL GIVE IT ONE PAT BEV AND
THREE JAY-Z SNARLS.
I'M ONLY GIVING FOUR.
MY MAIN REASON IS I'M GIVING IT
THE PAT BEV BECAUSE THEY WENT
PR.
IF THE REST OF THE TAKE WAS TO
SHUT DOWN THE BURNER ACCOUNTS
AND TO ONLY FOCUS ON THE MAIN
ACCOUNT, I COULD HAVE GIVEN IT
TWO PAT BEVS.
I THINK K.D. NEEDS TO FIRE OFF
TWEETS TO BE FULL EASY MONEY
SNIPER.
>> I'LL GIVE IT FIVE JAY-Zs.
>> WOW.
>> I RESPECT THE GENTLEMAN WHO
GAVE THE TAKE.
I UNDERSTAND WHERE HE WAS COMING
FROM.
K.D. SLANDER, K.D. NEEDS TO BE
ON THE INTERNET.
HOW IS HE GOING TO SLANDER
PEOPLE ON TWITTER IF HE'S NOT ON
TWITTER?
HE COULD DO IT LESS FREQUENTLY.
WE KNOW K.D. IS TWEETING FROM
HIS OWN ACCOUNT, WHICH IS WHY I
RESPECT HIM AS WELL.
OTHER GUYS, MAGIC, HE MAY HAVE
TEAMS.
AS MUCH AS I LOVE TOM BRADY'S
TWEETS, THEY'RE NOT COMING FROM
THE G.O.A.T. HIMSELF.
>> I HATE WHEN PEOPLE ARE LIKE
TOM BRADY IS UNDEFEATED.
YOU SHOULD LOSE TWITTER ACCESS
FOR A FULL DAY IF YOU THINK TOM
BRADY IS FIRING OFF THOSE
TWEETS.
>> HAS HE FIRED OFF ONE OR TWO,
MAYBE.
I FELL LIKE THERE'S A WHOLE
PROCESS NOW.
>> IF KEVIN DURANT CAN'T SAY
THAT ERYKAH BADU IS THICKER THAN
A KINDERGARTEN PENCIL, HE MIGHT
NOT PUT UP 50.
>> I MISS THE OLD DAYS OF
TWITTER WHEN EVERYBODY WAS
HITTING THAT RETWEET BUTTON.
>> YOU THINK THAT NOW PEOPLE ARE
AVOIDING RETWEETS OUT OF
JEALOUSY?
>> I DON'T KNOW.
BACK IN THE DAY WE WERE MORE
COMFORTABLE HITTING THAT WE
TWEET BUTTON.
>> WHAT IS K.D.'S AVATAR RIGHT
NOW?
>> IS IT SMALLS FROM --
>> YEAH.
>> FROM "SAND LOT."
>> IT'S SAD THAT IT'S ONE OF MY
FAVORITE MOVIES.
>> WHEN DO YOU EVER SEE A TWEET
GET 52,000 RETWEETS AND LIKES?
>> THAT'S WHAT I'M SAYING.
ALWAYS SHARES HIS FEELINGS.
THAT'S WHY WE NEED HIM ON
TWITTER.
>> MAN.
THAT'S -- OKAY.
SO YOU GAVE IT FIVE JAY-Zs, I
GAVE IT ONE PAT BEV AND THREE
JAY-
JAY-Zs.
>> IT'S GOOD, AND YOU MAY GET
ELEVATED.
>> WE ARE PICKING TWO TO REACH
THE FINALE OF THE "TAKE MASTERS"
TO THEN ARGUE WITH US AND EACH
OTHER.
I WILL CHECK THE B/R APP REALLY
QUICK.
SEE WHAT WE GOT HERE.
COPYING LeBRON, FLATTERY AT ITS
FINEST.
THE BRON SEXUAL CALLS K.D. THE
KING OF TWITTER.
WOULD YOU CONSIDER YOURSELF A --
>> I DON'T KNOW WHERE THAT
STARTED.
IT'S TIME TO END IT.
WE ALL HAVE PLAYERS WE SUPPORT
AND LIKE.
WHATEVER.
DID LeBRON CALLED ME THE
G.O.A.T.?
YEAH, HE HAS GOOD TASTE.
HE'S NOT THE ONLY ONE.
>> I CAN'T BELIEVE YOU GOT THAT
FROM LeBRON.
>> A LOT OF PEOPLE CAN'T.
I KNEW THE SLANDER WAS COMING
AND THE TROLLS.
>> WHEN HE TWEETED YOU, DID YOU
GET AN ALERT ON YOUR PHONE?
>> I THINK KYLE LONG OR SOMEBODY
HIT ME LIKE, YO, I SAW YOU GOT
THE BRON RETURN.
I WAS LIKE WHAT ARE YOU TALKING
ABOUT?
I SAW IT.
I SAID IT WILL BE GREAT,
PERSONALLY, PROFESSIONALLY --
>> SO YOU WERE CALM?
>> FOR SURE.
I WAS MORE DISAPPOINTED THAT IT
TOOK HIM SO LONG.
>> OUR SECOND SUBMISSION OF THE
NIGHT ON "TAKE MASTERS."
I HEAR IT'S ABOUT CHRIS PAUL.
>> THE MOST IMPORTANT PERSON IN
THE NBA PLAYOFFS HAS GOT TO BE
CHRIS PAUL'S DOCTOR.
IF HE DOESN'T COME BACK 1100%,
THEY'RE STRAIGHT TRASH.
STRAIGHT TRASH.
PUT ALL THE DOCTORS IN THAT.
>> CAN YOU REPLAY THE FIRST FIVE
SECONDS?
>> THE MOST IMPORTANT PERSON IN
THE NBA PLAYOFFS HAS TO BE CHRIS
PAUL'S DOCTOR.
WITH THE THUMB, IF HE DOESN'T
COME BACK 100%, THEY'RE STRAIGHT
TRASH.
STRAIGHT TRASH.
>> FOR A SECOND I THOUGHT HE
SAID THE THUNDER.
HE SAID THE SUNS ARE.
>> ZIBBY.
>> DO YOU KNOW HIM?
>> NO, BUT I LOVE THAT HE CAME
THROUGH WITH THE TRASH PROP.
>> WE HAD THAT WITH OUR LAST
"TAKE MASTERS," I WANT TO GIVE
PROPS TO ZIBBY WITH STRAIGHT
TRASH.
HE FELT THE BEGINNING WENT WELL
ENOUGH TO DROP THE PAPER.
I WILL GIVE THE -- MY INITIAL
THOUGHT IS CHRIS PAUL'S DOCTOR,
OKAY.
IT'S A GOOD PERSON.
IN TERMS OF THE EXECUTION OF IT,
IF HE'S NOT HEALTHY THE SUNS ARE
STRAIGHT TRASH.
HE TAILED OFF WITH IT.
WHAT I'M NOTICING ARE INITIAL
GOOD THOUGHTS BUT NOT GREAT
EXECUTION, AND NOT GOOD
FOLLOW-UP POINTS.
BUT I DID LIKE HIS PROP.
SO AS I THINK ABOUT MY GRADE,
YOUR INITIAL THOUGHT OF THIS
TAKE?
>> I THINK THE SUNS OBVIOUSLY
NEED CP3 TO GET OVER THE HUMP.
THE TEAM WAS SOLID WHEN HE WENT
OUT.
STILL RETAINED THAT ONE SEED.
ONLY TEAM TO WIN 60 GAMES THIS
YEAR, UNLESS I'M SMOKING
RECREATIONAL, WHICH I'M NOT.
I WOULD SAY IT'S GOING TO BE
TOUGH FOR THEM ANY WAY.
I DON'T KNOW IF THEY CAN BEAT
THE NETS OR BUCKS BECAUSE THEY
DIDN'T DO IT LAST YEAR.
I'LL SAY IT'S A GOOD TAKE.
LOVE THE PROP.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT THE PROP WAS,
I DON'T KNOW IF IT WAS TRASH OR
TISSUES.
IT WAS MORE LITTER THAN TRASH.
>> I'M SITTING HERE THINKING
WHAT OTHER ANGLES HE COULD HAVE
TAKEN.
MY TAKE HAS ALWAYS BEEN THAT
CHRIS PAUL GETTING HURT RIGHT
BEFORE THE ALL-STAR BREAK WAS
THE SMARTEST THING THAT HE DID.
HE GOT HIS INJURY OUT OF THE WAY
EARLY.
CHRIS PAUL'S DOCTOR, I'M
ACTUALLY GOING TO -- I'LL GO 1
PAT BEV AND FOUR JAY-Zs.
BECAUSE I ACTUALLY LIKE K.D.'S
PR MANAGER MORE THAN THIS.
I JUST -- I'M ALSO -- YEAH.
HE DIDN'T LAND THE PLANE,
JOSIAH.
HE DIDN'T LAND THE PLANE.
>> HE DIDN'T --
>> HE COULD HAVE GONE AND BEEN,
LIKE -- HE COULD HAVE GONE
SOME -- IT DIDN'T STICK WITH ME.
I'M SORRY.
IT DID NOT LAND WITH ME.
>> SHOUT OUT TO THE PRODUCTION
TEAM.
THEY GOT MOVEMENT ON THE
ANIMATIONS.
YOU'RE DOING A GREAT JOB.
I'LL GIVE IT TWO PAT BEVS AND
THREE JAY-ZSHs.
LIKE THE IDEA AND THE CONCEPT.
I WON'T SAY THE SUNS ARE
STRAIGHT TRASH WITHOUT CP3.
ARE THEY ELITE LEVEL?
NOT NECESSARILY.
I ROCK WITH ZIBBY.
GREAT NAME.
ZIBBY GETTING IT.
>> DANE SAID KENDALL JENNER IS
THE MOST IMPORTANT FACTOR.
THAT'S ANOTHER PERSON WHO COULD
V. BRO
HAVE BEEN BROUGHT UP HERE.
>> LEGS ARE IMPORTANT.
COLD WATER, THE ICE, DO WHAT YOU
WANT TO DO.
>> DAN DUVAL, THAT IS RIGHT
THERE, CP3 IS ALWAYS INJURED, IT
DOESN'T MATTER.
ASEAN, FORMER B/R GUY, THE SUNS
FAMOUS I WILL HAVE ONE OF THE
BEST MEDICAL STAFFS IN THE NBA.
SHAQ USED TO CALL THEM YUMS.
THEY TRY EXPERIMENTAL THERAPIES.
I THINK WHAT COULD HAVE BEEN
DONE HERE, WE COULD HAVE -- THE
TAKE COULD HAVE CREATED A
PERSON.
IT COULD HAVE BEEN CHRIS PAUL'S
MYTH
MYTHOLOGICAL -- I DON'T KNOW.
>> LOOK AT THAT.
>> I DON'T KNOW WHERE YOU'RE
GOING.
>> WE'LL TALK OFFLINE.
NOW WE'RE GOING TO TAKE NUMBER
THREE OF SIX.
I HAVE A NOTE HERE AND IT SAYS
SYRACUSE.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT THAT MEANS.
>> THAT FEELS LIKE HOME COOKING.
YOU KNOW, YOU WENT TO SYRACUSE.
PRODUCED A LOT OF PEOPLE IN THE
MEDIA INDUSTRY.
IF YOU NOTICE SYRACUSE GETS MORE
LOVE THAN IT DESERVES --
>> SHOUT OUT TO ZAV SAYING
LEFKOE, PLEASE RETIRE, I HATE
YOU.
THANKS FOR WATCHING.
LET'S GET TO TAKE NUMBER THREE
AND SEE WHAT IT IS.
>> PLEASE RETIRE.
I HATE YOU.
>> THE MOST IMPORTANT PERSON IN
THIS YEAR'S PLAYOFFS IS JIMMY
BUTLER'S ANGER MANAGEMENT COACH.
HAVE TO KEEP JIMMY IN CHECK OR
THAT LOCKER ROOM WILL EXPLODE IN
MIAMI.
ALSO, ADAM, GO CUSE, BABY.
>> CAN I START THIS ONE OFF?
>> YES.
>> HERE'S MY QUESTION.
HE SAID JIMMY BUTLER, BUT HE'S
WEARING A DWYANE WADE JERSEY.
>> OKAY.
>> I GOT TO NEW YORK OFF A POINT
FOR THAT.
IF HE WOULD HAVE WENT TO THE
HEAT AND COVERED IT OR DID ONE
OF THOSE ELABORATE THING WHERE
THEY TAKE THE TAPE AND GIVE ME
JIMMY'S NUMBER.
I RESPECT --
>> THE CARMELO ANTHONY --
>> THAT'S THE LAST TIME SYRACUSE
WAS GOOD AT ANYTHING.
>> I'M NOT EVEN A BIG SYRACUSE
GUY.
I HAVE NOT BEEN TO SYRACUSE
SINCE I GRADUATED.
>> THEY DON'T ROLL OUT THE RED
CARPET FOR YOU?
>> NO.
>> THAT'S PART OF MY ISSUE.
>> I GET THE SAME TEAM FROM UCLA
BASKETBALL SOCIAL MEDIA TEAM.
NO PROBLEM, GUYS.
STILL HERE.
>> I'LL SAY THIS, ONE, LET'S
FOCUS ON THE TAKE.
JIMMY BUTLER'S ANGER MANAGEMENT
COUNSELOR BECAUSE IF NOT, MIAMI
IS GOING TO FALL APART.
CLEARLY CHANNELING THE FIGHT
THAT HAPPENED EARLIER THIS YEAR
THAT JIMMY BUTLER GOT INTO A
FIGHT WITH ERIK SPOELSTRA AND
HAD TO BE SEPARATED.
UDONIS HASLEM CAME IN AND
SEPARATED THEM.
THE ISSUE I HAVE WITH THIS, I
THINK THE TAKE COULD HAVE BEEN
BETTER IF IT WAS FLIPPED.
THE FIGHT HAPPENED AND THEN THE
HEAT WENT ON A FIVE-GAME WINNING
STREAK.
SO I THINK THE TAKE COULD HAVE
BEEN HIS ANGER MANAGEMENT
PERSON, BUT ENCOURAGE HIM TO
FIGHT MORE TO CREATE ANGER THAT
CREATES MORE WINNING.
I THINK IT COULD HAVE BEEN
FLIPPED.
>> MY FAVORITE THING ABOUT THIS
CLIP, SPOELSTRA WANTED ALL THE
SMUG.
HE'S ABOUT 5'7" 5'8".
>> WHEN IT STARTED, YOU COULD
LOOK AT SPOELSTRA SAY DO YOU
WANT TO FIGHT ME?
THAT'S ONLY SAID BY SOMEBODY WHO
WANTS TO FIGHT.
>> HE HAS SOME GUNS.
HE HAS A GOOD AB ROUTINE.
UDONIS HASLEM, THE LIVING
LEGEND.
I DON'T KNOW WHO IN THE LEAGUE I
WOULD WANT TO FIGHT LESS THAN
UDONIS HASLEM.
GOT TO BE SOMEBODY.
MAYBE JAMES JOHNSON OR
SOMETHING.
I THINK HE'S A BLACK BELT.
>> HE IS.
I'M GOING TO SAY -- HE WENT AND
CAME AT ME AND HE TRIED TO BRIBE
ME.
>> SHOW LOVE TO SYRACUSE.
THE ORANGE PEOPLE.
>> THE THING THAT I TAKE MORE
SERIOUSLY THAN ANYTHING IS MY
PRIDE AS A TAKE MASTER.
I NEED TO SET A PRECEDENCE.
IF YOU'RE GOING TO COME IN HERE
AND TRY TO BRIBE ME WITH
SYRACUSE PARAPHERNALIA, I'M
GOING TO GO FIVE JAY-Zs.
>> THAT'S WHAT I WANTED TO SEE.
>> YOU CANNOT BRIBE YOUR WAY,
TALK YOUR WAY INTO BECOMING A
"TAKE MASTERS."
IF YOU THINK YOU'RE GOING TO
COME IN HERE AND BE LIKE, HEY, I
LIKE THE EAGLES.
I MIGHT BEND TO THAT ONE.
HE WENT WITH SYRACUSE.
I'M GOING FIVE.
CHRISTIAN, I APPRECIATE IT.
I KNOW -- I APPRECIATE THE PROP.
BUT I FELT LIKE HE WAS TRYING TO
BRIBE ME.
THAT CANNOT BE ALLOWED.
>> YOU GAVE HIM FIVE JAY-Zs?
>> YOU THOUGHT I WAS GIVING HIM
FIVE PAT BEVS?
>> I HAD THE PEOPLE READY.
>> NO, I NEED TO SET A
PRECEDENCE.
>> I THOUGHT THIS IS WHAT YOU
WERE DOING.
I HAD THE EAGLES CUED UP.
I KNOW YOU'RE A PHILADELPHIA
GUY, IN YOUR HEART.
>> YEAH.
>> NO SWINE.
>> I'LL GIVE HIM ONE PAT BEV AND
FOUR JAY-Zs.
I THINK THAT ANGER IS NEEDED.
WE KNOW JIMMY BUTLER IS THE MAN,
ESPECIALLY WHEN HE'S ANGRY.
>> HE WANTS HIM TO NOT BE ANGRY.
>> I NEED MORE ANGER, THAT'S WHY
I GAVE HIM THE FOUR JAY-Zs.
I DO LIKE THAT CARMELO ANTHONY
JERSEY.
AND I DO LIKE WHITE PEOPLE
WEARING BLACK PEOPLES JERSEY.
>> WHO ELSE IS HE GOING TO WEAR?
>> GERRY WITH A G., GOT TO
RESPECT IT.
>> IF HE HAD COME ON A MAX
STRUSS JERSEY OR A TYLER HERRO
JERSEY --
>> RESPECTABLE.
I DO LIKE THAT COLORWAY.
>> I FEEL LIKE I'M BEING VERY
HARSH.
>> NO LOVE FOR SYRACUSE.
DO YOU HAVE A SECRET CUS EE DAPR
HANDSHAKE?
>> WE'RE LEARNING SOMETHING
RIGHT NOW.
WHEN PEOPLE COME UP TO ME AND
SAY SYRACUSE, I'M NOT EXCITED.
>> YOU'RE NOT LIKE DAP UP?
>> NO, PEOPLE LIKE YOU GO YOU
HAVE A SYRACUSE MAFIA?
NUMBER ONE, I DIDN'T GET INTO
NEWHOUSE OUT OF HIGH SCHOOL.
WHEN I GOT IN THERE ORIGINALLY,
THEY'RE LIKE YOU'RE NOT ACTUALLY
A SYRACUSE GUY.
I WAS LIKE I GUESS I'M NOT.
I ALWAYS HAD THE CHIP ON MY
SHOULDER, SO I DON'T CLAIM IT
LIKE THAT.
I REALLY DON'T.
>> I RESPECT IT.
NOW YOU'RE GETTING IT AT A
HIGHER LEVEL THAN MOST SYRACUSE
ALUMS.
>> THEN YOU HAVE SOMEBODY LIKE
Z
ZAVIAN, HE'S HOME SCHOOLED.
HE SPILLS ON HIS SHIRT WHEN HE
EATS AND JOINS US IN THE B/R APP
AND WATCHES.
>> HE'S A 305 GUY.
LEFT K
CAN WE FIGHT?
>> NEXT TIME WE DO "TAKE
MASTERS."
YOU SUBMIT A VIDEO.
I'LL VENMO YOU 50 BUCKS, BUT YOU
HAVE TO ALLOW YOURSELF TO BE
TAKE MASTERED.
LET'S GO TO THE FOURTH TAKE AND
SEE WHERE THEY GO.
IT'S ABOUT THE CELTICS.
>> THE MOST IMPORTANT PERSON IN
THE NBA PLAYOFFS THIS YEAR IS
THE MAN WHO GOT THE BOSTON
CELTICS TATTOOED ON HIS ARM.
THE CELTICS HAVE TO WIN FOR HIM
OR ELSE WHAT IS GOING TO HAPPEN?
SHAME, HUMILIATION, REGRET?
THOSE ARE WORDS THAT HUMANS
WON'T WANT TO SAY.
THE CELTICS NEED TO WIN FOR THAT
GUY.
NK
>> IF SOMEBODY COULD GIVE ME
INFORMATION WHEN THAT PICTURE
WAS POSTED, IT'S IMPORTANT.
THE BOSTON CELTICS BEGAN THE NEW
YEAR WITH A CRAZY RUN.
THEY WERE LIKE THE NUMBER ONE
DEFENSE IN THE NBA SINCE THE
TURN OF THE YEAR.
I FEEL LIKE THIS POSTED EVEN
BEFORE THAT.
I LOVE THIS TAKE A LOT.
MARCH 22nd.
SO IT WAS LATER.
>> WE ARE THIS ALREADY ON THE
RUN?
>> THEY WERE ON THE RUN.
IN YOU LOOK, THAT'S HOW THAT
BANNER WOULD LOOK.
I LOVE PEOPLE THAT GET THESE
TATTOOS BEFORE THE PLAYOFFS EVEN
START.
I'M NOT READY TO GIVE MY GRADE
YET.
I'M TRYING TO FACTOR IN THE TAKE
ITSELF.
THE FIRST IS THE IDEA, THE
CONCEPT, TATTOO GUY.
THE SECOND PART WAS THEY NEED TO
WIN FOUR HIM.
SO IT'S LIKE A MOTIVATION.
WHAT IS YOUR INITIAL FEEL OF
THIS TAKE?
>> I DO NOT LIKE THE CELTICS.
I DO NOT LIKE CELTICS TWITTER,
BUT I HAVE SOME LEVEL OF
ADMIRATION AND RESPECT FOR A
HUMAN BEING THAT LITERALLY GETS
THE CHAMPIONSHIP FLAG TATTOOED
ON THEMSELVES.
THE LIKELIHOOD OF IT HAPPENING
IS EMBARRASSING.
YOU CAN UPDATE THE NUMBER TO
THREE, FOUR.
MAYBE UPDATE IT TO 3022.
AT LEAST GIVE YOURSELF SOME
LEEWAY.
AND THE REDNESS OF THE ARM.
YOU COULD TELL THAT HURT A LOT.
I'LL GO AHEAD AND SAY -- I DON'T
RESPECT THE CELTICS, BUT I
RESPECT THAT TAKE.
THE GENTLEMAN PUT A LOT OF
THOUGHT INTO IT.
>> YES.
>> I APPRECIATE THAT.
IF I HAD TO GIVE IT A SCORE.
I'M GOING TO GO TWO PAT BEVS,
THREE JAY-Zs.
LOOK AT HIS GRILL, HE LOOKS LIKE
HARLOW.
>> IS THERE A CHANCE HE'S
ACTUALLY THE TATTOO GUY?
>> OH, HE'S THE ONE --
>> HE'S THE ONE.
AND NOW -- NOW WE'RE SHOWING WHY
WE'RE "TAKE MASTERS."
>> FOR SURE.
>> IF HE WOULD HAVE STARTED THAT
AND THEN ENDED THE VIDEO BY
TURNING HIS SHOULDER INTO IT,
EVEN IF HE JUST SHARPIED IT ON
THERE, NOW YOU GO FROM MAYBE TWO
PAT BEVS TO FOUR PAT BEVS.
THE REASON I LIKE THIS TAKE IS,
IF THE CELTICS KNOCK OFF THE
NETS AND ADVANCE, I'M WAITING
FOR THE LOCAL NEWS STORY WHERE
THEY FIND THE TATTOO GUY AND
THEY'RE INTERVIEWING HIM.
HE SITS COURTSIDE.
I THINK TATTOO ARM GUY,
ESPECIALLY IN A CITY LIKE
BOSTON, COULD BECOME A CENTRAL
FIGURE.
REMEMBER THE OLD LADY THAT WAS
SITTING NEXT TO TERRY ROZIER
WHEN HE WAS SCARY TERRY?
>> YEAH.
>> I'M GOING TO GIVE THIS THREE
PAT BEVS, TWO JAY-ZSJ
PAT BEVS, TWO JAYAY-Zs.
I THOUGHT IT WAS A GOOD CONCEPT,
REASONING.
THE TWO JAY-Zs FOR LACK OF PROPS
AND REASONING.
THE TWO BECAUSE YOU'RE NOT A
CELTICS FAN AND I'M NOT A
CELTICS FAN EITHER.
>> I RESPECT IT.
HE MADE UP WHAT HE WAS ABLE TO
DO WITH THE SQUAD THIS SEASON.
DESERVES MORE LOVE FOR COACH OF
THE YEAR DISCUSSION, IT IS WHAT
IT IS.
I RESPECT THE GUY.
>> SO THAT ONE I FELT LIKE KIND
OF HIT A BIT.
I LIKE IT.
THAT WAS TAKE NUMBER FOUR.
>> DO TATTOO GUYS HAVE
RELATIONSHIPS WITH THE TATTOO
REMOVAL PEOPLE?
>> YOU'RE RIGHT.
WE HAVE NOT GOTTEN THE FOLLOW-UP
ON THE OTHER PEOPLE THAT DID NOT
FOLLOW THROUGH.
>> WHOEVER TATTOOED, I DON'T
KNOW IF YOU REMEMBER THE PERSON
WHO GOT DRAKE TATTOOED ON THEIR
FOREHEAD.
>> THIS IS THE PERSON?
>> COULD BE HIS COUSIN.
>> MAN.
>> WHAT WAS THE DRAKE ONE?
>> SOMEONE GOT DRAKE TATTOOED ON
THEIR FOREHEAD AND DRAKE GOT MAD
AT IT.
THERE'S ONLY A COUPLE PLACES IN
BOSTON WHERE YOU CAN GET THAT
LEGITIMATELY AND THEY'LL DO IT
FOR YOU.
>> JAMAAL WILLIAMS 671 SAYING
EVERY CELTICS FAN REMINDS ME OF
THE SUNS IN FOUR PUNCHING GUY.
>> THAT'S A GOOD TAKE.
IF YOU WOULD HAVE MADE A VIDEO,
YOU COULD HAVE GOT ON THE SHOW
AND MIGHT HAVE GOTTEN SOME
FANFARE AND LOVE OUT OF IT.
>> WOW.
WOW.
>> DRAKE HAS THAT TYPE OF IMPACT
ON PEOPLE.
>> THAT IS SO REGRETTABLE.
COULD YOU MAKE A TAKE TO WHY
THAT TATTOO IS A GOOD TATTOO?
ARE YOU SUCH A "TAKE MASTERS"
THAT YOU COULD SPIN THAT?
>> IF YOU'RE GOING TO MARRY A
GUY NAMED DRAKE, MAYBE.
THE "K" LOOKS JANKY.
THEY NEED TO DO FOLLOW-UP ON IT.
>> COULD YOU IMAGINE GETTING
DRAKE'S TATTOO ON YOUR FOREHEAD
AND DRAKE COMES OUT AND SAYS HE
DOESN'T LIKE IT?
THE ONLY THING YOU'RE HOPING FOR
IS COME TO MY NEXT SHOW.
>> NOT EVEN A TICKET, GENERAL
POPULATION, UNFORTUNATE.
>> LET'S KEEP IT MOVING.
TAKE NUMBER FIVE IS ABOUT JAMES
HARDEN AND THE PHILADELPHIA
76ers.
>> THE MOST IMPORTANT PERSON IN
THE NBA PLAYOFFS IS JAMES
HARDEN'S BARBER.
THERE'S A LOT OF PRESSURE ON
HARDEN'S ABILITY TO PERFORM.
HARDEN WON'T PLAY WELL IF HIS
BEARD IS LOPSIDED FLYING IN THE
WIN.
THIS PICTURE OF HIS BEARD, THE
STRAGGLER ON THE LEFT, THIS IS
FROM APRIL 7th.
THIS PICTURE, THIS BEARD, IT'S
PERFECT.
THE 76ers WON THIS DAY, THERE'S
A MASSIVE CONNECTION HERE.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> I -- I -- GO.
I WANT YOU TO GO.
>> YOU'RE A SIXERS FAN.
I KNEW YOU WOULD LOVE THIS ONE
FROM THE JUMP.
I DID APPRECIATE HOW SHE CAME
THROUGH WITH THE TIKTOK GREEN
SCREEN.
I LOVE WHEN THEY MAKE THE VIDEOS
WHERE THEY CAN POINT TO WHATEVER
GOES ON.
NOW THAT I SEE THE GROOMED BEARD
VERSUS THE UNGROOMED BEARD,
VALID POINT.
>> I WANT YOU TO KNOW MY
REACTION, MY STANDING OVATION
AND THE GRADES I'M ABOUT TO GIVE
HAVE NOTHING TO DO WITH THE FACT
THAT IT IS THE PHILADELPHIA
76ers.
NOTHING TO DO WITH IT.
>> OKAY.
>> IT HAS EVERYTHING TO DO WITH
WHAT WE SAW -- IS THAT JAMES
HARDEN?
>> THAT'S A BEAUTIFUL BEARD.
>> WOW.
>> THERE WAS A LITTLE EDITING.
THERE WAS A FULL PRESENTATION.
IT WASN'T LIKE HEY, I HOPE I DO
A GOOD 20 SECONDS.
THERE WAS EVIDENCE.
THERE WAS, HEY, BAD BEARD, LOSE.
GOOD BEARD, WIN.
THERE WAS PRESENTATION.
THERE WAS DELIVERY.
I AM GIVING THIS FIVE PAT BEVS.
>> WHOA!
>> WHAT YOU JUST WITNESSED WAS A
THOUGHT OUT TAKE THAT WAS
PRODUCED, DELIVERED, EDITED AND
EXECUTED.
THERE'S FIVE PAT BEVS SMILING.
AND JUST LIKE THE TIMBERWOLVES
AND PAT BEVS I'M PROBABLY A
LITTLE BIT OVERHYPED THAN I
SHOULD BE.
>> JUMP ON THE TABLE, TAKE THE
SHIRT OFF.
THROW IT INTO THE CROWD.
>> WOW.
>> I'LL GIVE HER THREE PAT BEVSs
AND TWO JAY-Zs.
>> WHAT WAS MISSING?
>> I'M JUST HATING.
REALLY STILL SALTY THAT LeBRON
AND THE LAKERS ARE NOT IN THE
PLAYOFFS.
I'M TAKING THAT OUT ON ALL OUR
"TAKE MASTERS" GUESTS.
T
I APPRECIATED THE EDITING, THE
TIKTOK STYLE, ALL THE POINTS.
I INTERVIEWED HIS MOM IN 2011,
HIS BEARD WAS STILL GROWING, HE
ALWAYS SAID AT ARIZONA STATE HE
LOOKED SO YOUNG SO HE GREW THE
BEARD.
AT SOME POINT HE WILL HAVE TO
SHAVE IT OFF.
>> WHEN YOU END UP DOING YOUR
TAKE, ZAVIAN, THIS IS HOW IT HAS
TO GO.
USE THE ONE OR TWO BRAIN CELLS
STILL FUNCTIONING, DO A LITTLE
EDITING.
YOU CAN FINGER PAINT IF THAT'S
EASIER FOR YOU.
PROCESS IT, COMPLETE THOUGHTS
AND THEN DELIVER.
THAT WAS PHENOMENAL.
THERE'S ANOTHER SIXERS TAKE.
>> OKAY.
>> I'M NOT GOING TO BE THAT EASY
OF A GRADER.
>> ALL THEY HAVE TO DO IS SAY
SIXERS AND THEY GET TWO PAT BEVS
OUT OF YOU.
>> I'LL PROVE YOU WRONG.
>> I'M GOING WITH JOEL EMBIID
UBER EATS DRIVER.
JOEL EMBIID IS THE TYPE OF GUY
WHO NEEDS A SNACK, A BURGER,
CHICKEN WINGS RIGHT BEFORE THE
GAME.
THAT DRIVER HAS TO BE VIGILANT
SO HE CAN STAY ENUSED DURING THE
PLAYOFFS.
>> OKAY.
SO THE --
>> LEGEND.
>> HE IS ABOUT TO ORDER A SNACK
AS WELL.
MY MAN IS TOASTED.
CAN WE --
>> HE IS A CALIFORNIAN.
WE DO THINGS IN CALIFORNIA.
>> CAN WE WATCH THE BEGINNING OF
THAT AND SEE THE SMILE ON HIS
FACE?
>> IT COULD BE A SUN GLARE.
>> ME PERSONALLY, I'M GOING WITH
JOEL EMBIID --
>> THE WAY HE SAID PERSONALLY.
PERSONALLY.
>> HE NEEDS A SNACK.
A BURGER.
>> ALL RIGHT.
SO --
>> WAS HE PROJECTING
BURGER/CHICKEN WINGS?
>> LOOK AT HIS FACE RIGHT THERE.
MY MAN IS FEELING GREAT.
I WANT TO KNOW WHY THE CONCEPT
OF JOEL EMBIID'S UBER EATS
DRIVER MADE YOU AUDIBLY LAUGH
FOR THE FIRST TIME TODAY.
WE'VE HEARD A LOT OF OTHER
PEOPLE.
WHEN YOU HEARD THAT, YOU
GIGGLED, WHY?
>> I'M A POSTMATES GUY.
I RESPECT THE NUANCE, THE
THOUGHTS THAT WENT INTO IT.
THE UBER EATS DRIVER.
SO MANY DIFFERENT OPTIONS --
>> YOU THINK OF THE THIRD TIER
DELIVERY GUY.
>> EMBIID WOULD HAVE SOMETHING
GOING ON --
>> NICE.
>> THE MAN IS EATING GRAPES.
SHOUT OUT TO BIG HEAVY IN LAKER
NATION, MAKES A LOT OF GOOD
CONTENT FOR THE INTERNET.
APPRECIATE HIM SENDING THAT IN.
I'M GOING TO ROCK WITH IT.
I'LL GIVE THREE PAT BEVS.
>> YOUR FIRST THREE PAT BEVS.
>> I'LL GIVE HIM FOUR.
HOME COMING.
LIKE YOU GAVE THE FIVE TO THE
SIXERS TAKE.
I'LL GIVE FOUR TO THIS ONE.
>> SO I, LIKE YOU, HEARD JOEL
EMBIID'S UBER EATS DELIVERY
DRIVER, I WENT WHERE IS HE GOING
TO GO HERE?
THE LANDING OF THE PLANE AS --
BECAUSE HE'S HUNGRY AND NEEDS
SNACKS, I DIDN'T REALLY FEEL IT.
JUST BECAUSE WE'RE ALL HUNGRY
AND WE ALL LIKE SNACKS.
>> I'M HUNGRY RIGHT NOW.
I'LL KEEP IT REAL.
>> I'M STARVING.
>> I'LL GO TWO PAT BEVS, THREE
JAY-Zs.
>> SORRY.
HE GOT YOU.
>> I APPRECIATE WHAT YOU DID FOR
US.
I THINK IT WAS GREAT.
I CANNOT STOP STARING AT YOUR
FACE.
SO ACTUALLY -- I'LL SWITCH TO
THREE PAT BEVS AND TWO JAY-Zs
SOLELY BECAUSE OF THIS FACE
RIGHT HERE.
>> LOOK AT THE TEAM AGAIN.
>> THEY DID THAT SO QUICK.
>> THEY'RE ON IT.
THEY'RE ACTUALLY WATCHING THE
SHOW AND LISTENING.
WHEN I WAS ON THAT SIDE, I WOULD
NEVER PAY ATTENTION.
I WOULD BE MF'ing TALENT UNDER
MY BREATH AND TALKING DOWN TO
THEM.
A DIFFERENT TIME.
>> BUT THE PETTIESTLA,
APPRECIATE YOU.
WE'VE SEEN JOEL EMBIID RIGHT
HERE EATING GRAPES, EATING A
BURGER.
WHAT DO YOU THINK JOEL EMBIID'S
GO-TO MEAL IS?
>> I THINK HE'S GOING TO BE
EATING AN "L" IN THE NEAR
FUTURE.
I DON'T KNOW.
>> THAT WAS GOOD.
>> IF I'M EMBIID, I WOULD SAY --
EVERYBODY LIKES PAT AND JIM'S,
THE CHEESESTEAKS SPOT.
I HAD ONE IN CHESTER.
DEFINITELY HAVE A GREASE STAIN.
RUINED A NICE PAIR OF SHORTS
WITH THE GREASE.
THERE'S NOTHING THAT BEATS A
CHEESESTEAK.
WHOEVER CAME UP WITH IT, SALUTE
YOU.
>> WE ARE NOW GOING TO GO TO --
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> OH, MY GOSH.
>> THE ORIGINAL.
>> BEFORE WE BRING ON TWO OF OUR
TAKEES, IT'S LESS TO CROWN AS IT
IS TO HAVE SOME CONSTRUCTIVE
FEEDBACK.
>> FIGHT TO THE DEATH.
>> WE ARE ALSO GOING TO SHARE
SOME OF OUR OWN TAKES.
I'LL GO FIRST.
I BELIEVE THAT THE MOST
IMPORTANT PERSON IN THE NBA
PLAYOFFS IS THE MASSEUSE OF ONE
LUKA DONCIC.
>> OKAY.
>> I BELIEVE THAT LUKA HAS A
CHANCE TO BE A DWYANE WADE OR
ANOTHER ONE OF THOSE SUPERSTARS
THAT CAME OUT OF NOWHERE IN,
LIKE, THEIR THIRD YEAR.
WE WEREN'T EXPECTING IT, LIKE
DWAYNE DID WITH THE HEAT AGAINST
THE MAVS, BUT IT'S A SWEDISH
WOMAN NAMED OLGA, THAT WILL PUT
THAT POINTY SWEDISH ELBOW INTO
LUKA'S CALF AND UNLOCK IT AND
HAVING HIM DOING THAT FACE.
HE'LL BE SITTING FACE DOWN ON
THE TABLE GOING OH!
HE WON'T BE ABLE TO HANDLE IT.
I'LL GET UP, ROTATE HIS FOOT AND
DROP 45 ON THE JAZZ.
THAT'S WHERE IT'S INTERESTING.
I THINK LUKA'S DWYANE WADE
MOMENT COMES AGAINST THE TEAM
THAT DWYANE WADE OWNS, IT'S ALL
BECAUSE OF OLGA YVEMSTREMSKY.
I BELIEVE THAT YOU HAVE A GIF
THAT YOU ARE --
>> YOU CAN SEE IT.
I CAN'T GET YOUR RESPONSE.
YOU SAW IT GETTING TYPED.
I WILL SAY I DON'T KNOW ABOUT
THAT ONE, CHIEF.
LUKA -- HE'S GOING TO BE A STAR
ONE DAY.
YOU MENTIONED DWYANE WADE,
DWYANE WADE HAD SORT OF PRIME
SHAQ.
>> YEAH.
>> I'LL SAY I DON'T KNOW ABOUT
THAT ONE, CHIEF.
LOOK, I RESPECT IT.
HOPEFULLY LUKA IS DOING WELL.
JASON KIDD CAUGHT THE IRE OF A
LOT OF MAVS FANS WITH THE
DECISION TO PLAY LUKA IN THAT
GAME.
IT'S TOUGH WHEN YOU SEE THOSE
THINGS HAPPEN.
IT'S LIKE DAMN, IS OUR SEASON
OVER?
I THINK HE'LL HAVE ENOUGH TIME
TO REJUVENATE, GET LOOSE.
HE WON'T GET OUT OF THE SECOND
ROUND.
KEEP IT REAL.
NO MATTER HOW GOOD THAT MASSEUSE
IS, HE'S GETTING BUCKETED.
>> COULD YOU IMAGINE IF HE TOOK
DOWN THE SUNS BY HIMSELF?
>> IF LUKA BEATS THE SUNS, WE
CAN HAVE DISCUSSIONS.
I WOULD SAY HE'S BETTER THAN
TRAE AT THAT POINT.
>> YOU HAVE TRAE OVER LUKA?
>> YOU KNOW MY AFFINITY FOR
LIGHT-SKINNED HOOPERS.
I WAS NEVER A FAN WHEN IT WAS
LUKA STARTED OFF HOT.
OH, THERE'S NO WAY THAT HE'S ON
THAT LEVEL.
TRAE GETS TO THE EASTERN
CONFERENCE FINALS.
>> WHAT IS YOUR TAKE BEFORE WE
GET TO OUR TAKE SUBMITTERS?
>> THE MOST IMPORTANT PERSON IN
THIS PLAYOFFS IS GOING TO BE BEN
SIMMONS.
WE'VE SEEN BEN ROCKING THE GREEN
LEATHER DURING THE PLAY-IN GAME.
>> LAMBSKIN.
>> LAMBSKIN?
>> LAMBSKIN PRADA.
>> 100% LAMBSKIN.
>> ANY OF THAT STUFF, THERE'S
GOING TO BE A LOT OF STICKAGE IN
THE THIGH AREA, SWEATINESS.
I'M GETTING HOT RIGHT NOW, I'M
WEARING A T SHIRT.
I RESPECT THE LOOK.
I WOULD APPRECIATE IT MORE IF HE
WAS IN SWEATS AND A DINGY SHIRT.
>> YOU HAVE AN ISSUE WITH GUYS
WEARING NICE CLOTHES ON THE
BENCH WHEN THEY'RE NOT GOING TO
PLAY.
>> IT'S LIKE KENDRICK WEARING
THE RED EDDIE MURPHY PANTS.
GREAT LOOKING OUTFIT, BUT YOU
HAVE NOT PLAYED A GAME ALL
SEASON.
>> YOU KNOW HE'S WEARING THAT
FOR WHOEVER HE IS SITTING ACROSS
FROM.
>> GREAT FIT FOR THE CLUBS, BUT
IT'S A FIT I NEED TO SEE --
>> NOT IN BROOKLYN.
>> YOU DON'T ROCK WITH THAT?
>> THAT'S ONE OF YOUR L.A. CLUB
OUTFITS.
>> THAT'S WHY WE HAVE MORE SWAG
THAN YOU GUYS.
>> DEBATABLE.
THAT'S A TAKE UNTO ITSELF.
YOU THINK HE'S MOST IMPORTANT
BECAUSE IF HE PLAYS --
>> IF HE PLAYS, NETS WILL WIN
THE CHAMPIONSHIPS.
IF HE DOESN'T PLAY, GIANNIS.
>> WE'RE NOW GOING TO GO TO ONE
OF OUR TAKEEES.
>> OKAY.
>> UP FOR THIS SESSION'S "TAKE
MASTERS."
WITHOUT TELLING ME WHO IT IS,
LET'S POP THIS PERSON UP AND SEE
WHO WE HAVE THAT HAS MADE THE
CUT ACCORDING TO OUR PRODUCERS.
THEY TABULATED ALL OF THE PAT
BEV HEADS.
WHO IS YOUR FIRST TAKEE
SUBMISSION?
WHO DO WE GOT.
WOW.
I'M SO MHAPPY.
>> ARE YOU AT WORK?
>> NO, I'M WALKING TO THE
DEN
DENTIST.
>> OKAY.
GET IT IN.
>> GIVE US YOUR NAME AND HOW
MUCH RESEARCH DID YOU GIVE --
DID YOU PUT IN FOR THAT JAMES
HARDEN TAKE?
I'LL GET OUT OF YOUR WAY.
>> MY NAME IS PAIGE.
I WOULD SAY I PUT IN QUITE A
LITTLE BIT OF RESEARCH.
I LOOKED WHEN THE 76ers WON,
WHEN THEY LOST.
I CHECKED OUT HIS BEARD, THEN I
MADE THE COMPARISON.
I NOTICED, YOU KNOW, COMMON
DENOMINATOR.
>> I HAVE NEVER GIVEN FIVE
THUMBS UP BEFORE.
I JUST WANT TO KNOW, YOUR
REACTION, DID YOU THINK IT WOULD
BE THAT GOOD?
ARE YOU IMPRESSED?
JOSIAH DID NOT GIVE YOU FIVE PAT
BEVS.
HOW DO YOU FEEL ABOUT THAT?
>> I DID NOT.
>> OH, MY GOD, THAT KIND OF
UPSETS ME.
I THOUGHT IT WAS PRETTY GOOD.
I WAS ALSO SUPPLIRPRISED.
I THOUGHT EVERYONE ELSE HAD GOOD
IDEAS, TOO.
I'M FLATTERED.
>> SOMEONE WITH GREAT WIFI,
YOU'RE GETTING DENTAL WORK.
WHAT'S GOING ON?
CROWN, GENERAL CLEANING?
>> I NEVER HAD A CAVITY IN MY
LIFE.
WEIRD BRAG.
THAT'S PRETTY COOL.
I'M GOING FOR YOUR YEARLY.
YOU GO ONCE EVERY SIX MONTHS OR
A YEAR.
I'M JUST BEING, YOU KNOW, ON TOP
OF THINGS.
>> ALL RIGHT.
BE CAREFUL.
THEY'RE KNOWN FOR GETTING YOU,
THEY LOVE TO DIP IN THAT -- IF
YOU HAVE HEALTH COVERAGE, THEY
LIKE TO REACH THAT MAXIMUM.
>> DON'T FALL FOR THE $400
WHITENING THAT THEY'RE GOING TO
OFFER YOU FOR NO REASON.
>> NEVER.
>> LASTLY, YOUR REACTION, WHOSE
TAKE WAS BETTER?
LUKA'S MASSEUSE OR BEN SIMMONS
FROM US?
>> YOU GUYS FOR SURE.
>> WHICH ONE?
LUKA'S MASSEUSE OR --
>> BET ON BLACK.
>> BEN SIMMONS.
BEN SIMMONS.
>> I'M A TAKE MASTER.
>> ALL RIGHT, PAIGE.
WHAT WAS GOOD.
PAIGE, YOU JUST -- HOW FAR ARE
YOU FROM THE DENTIST?
HOW MANY BLOCKS?
>> IT'S ON 24th, I'M ON 14th.
>> TEN BLOCKS.
STAY ON FOR, LIKE, TWO MORE
MINUTES.
>> OKAY.
I'M HERE FOR YOU GUYS.
>> I WOULD HAVE DROVE THAT.
14th TO 24th -- SOUNDS LIKE A
GREAT DRIVE.
>> NO WAY.
TEN BLOCKS IS PERFECT.
ASIA, DO WE HAVE ANYBODY ELSE ON
THE LINE?
IS THAT IT?
PAIGE IS GONE.
DO WE HAVE ONE MORE?
IS THAT OUR OFFICIAL WINNER?
WE HAVE ONE MORE.
THIS ONE MIGHT BE MORE -- OH.
>> THE LEGEND.
>> OKAY.
>> SO THIS IS BOSTON CELTICS
CHAMPIONSHIP GUY.
>> TATTOO.
>> ARE YOU RELATED TO THAT DUDE?
>> I'M NOT.
I DO WANT TO CLARIFY, I'M A
LASHG
LAKERS FAN.
I WANTED TO MAKE MY TAKE
OBJECTIVE.
I THINK THAT'S THE POINT OF IT.
>> THAT'S FINE.
THAT'S FINE.
>> I HAD TO TELL YOU, JOSIAH, AS
ANOTHER LAKER FAN, JUST SO YOU
KNOW.
>> THE PURPLE AND GOLD
SWEATSHIRT.
I LIKE THE SWEATSHIRT.
PHENOMENAL.
BALLER.
>> THAT CHANGES MY OPINION.
YEAH.
I MIGHT HAVE --
>> YOU HAVE COMPLETELY THROWN
OFF OUR JUDGING SYSTEM BY
REVEALING YOU'RE A LAKERS FAN.
YOUR REACTION TO OUR CRITICISM
OF YOUR TAKE?
AFTER YOU HEARD THAT, WHAT WOULD
YOU HAVE CHANGED?
>> YOU KNOW, I DO PRIDE MYSELF
ON, YOU KNOW, A GOOD TAKE.
I LIKE MY TAKE.
I REALLY LIKE YOUR IDEA OF
HAVING A SHARPIE OF THAT TATTOO.
I THINK THAT WOULD HAVE TAKEN IT
NEXT LEVEL, MAYBE EVEN GARNERED
TAKE MASTER.
>> WHAT IS YOUR FIRST NAME?
>> ELI.
>> ELI, STAY ON THE LINES.
WE'LL TALK TO ONE MORE PERSON.
THANK YOU.
ELI, SUCKING UP TO YOU WITH THE
LAKERS.
SMART MOVE.
>> ONE.
WINNER.
>> WE HAVE ONE MORE PERSON THAT
WE'LL CHECK IN WITH.
WE HAVE PAIGE, IT IS KATIE'S PR
MANAGER.
WHAT'S YOUR FIRST NAME?
>> KENDALL.
>> KENDALL, THE CURL IS FLUFFY,
I WILL SAY THAT.
IT'S ELABORATE.
I'M A BIG ADVOCATE FOR CURLS.
IF I COULD GROW MY HAIR
AGAIN --.
THAT'S HOW YOU WOULD DO IT.
>> FOR SURE.
>> WE DID LIKE YOUR TAKE, BUT WE
WENT THE OPPOSITE WAY AND SAID
WE NEEDED K.D. ON SOCIAL MEDIA.
WHEN YOU HEARD THAT, DID YOU
AGREE WITH US OR WOULD YOU LIKE
TO DEFEND YOUR TAKE?
>> I'LL DEFEND.
I KNOW WHERE YOU'RE COMING FROM.
I LOVE K.D. TALKING ABOUT THE
DISCOVERY CHANNEL, STRINGING
SCAR JO'S BATH WATER, THOSE ARE
CLASSICS, BUT WE'RE GOING INTO
THE PLAYOFFS NOW.
K.D. CAN BE AN EMOTIONAL DUDE.
HE HEARS EVERYTHING, HE READS
EVERYTHING.
TAKE A PAGE OUT OF BRON'S BOOK,
BE OFF.
IF HE'S NON-SOCIAL, HE ONLY HAS
TWO AVENUES TO TAKE OUT HIS
ANGER, ON THE COURT, OR
POST-GAME PRESSERS.
K.D. KING OF SOME QUOTABLES.
YOU REMEMBER WHO I AM.
I'M KEVIN DURANT.
WE'LL GET MORE OF THOSE.
>> ARE YOU A NETS FAN?
>> I'M NOT.
I'M ACTUALLY A SPURS FAN, BUT
I'M A FAN OF K.D.
SO I WANT K.D. TO PERFORM.
THIS IS YEAR THREE OF THE NETS.
THEY HAVEN'T COME TOGETHER YET.
THIS IS THE TIME, K.D., IT'S
YOUR CHANCE, LOCK IN.
YOU CAN GET BACK ON SOCIAL,
CELEBRATE, DO EVERYTHING AFTER
YOU WIN.
>> SO YOU'RE SAYING SAVE THOSE
TWEETS UNTIL WHEN YOU WIN THE
CHAMPIONSHIP AND COME WITH THAT
HAMMER.
EMBIID, WITH THE FUNERAL TRADE
WHEN BEN SIMMONS GOT TRADED, TOO
EARLY.
SAVE THAT FOR THE PLAYOFFS.
>> YOU KNOW YOU HAVE TO HIT THAT
POCKET.
>> I KNOW.
I'M AN ENGAGEMENT GUY.
I LIKE GETTING OLD TAKES
EXPOSED, BECAUSE THEY CONTINUE
TO GET THE NUMBERS UP.
I GET JOBS LIKE THIS.
I APPRECIATE THE WAY YOU
DEFENDED YOUR TAKE.
I THINK I GAVE FIVE JAY-Zs.
I WILL TAKE A COUPLE BACK AND
GIVE HIM TWO PAT BEVS.
I'M ROCKING WITH THE CURL.
THREE PAT BEVS.
>> TAKE KENDALL OFF THE SCREEN
BEFORE HE GETS ANOTHER PAT BEV.
>> THE FLOSSY CURLS ARE KEY.
>> GET HIM OFF.
IT'S KENDALL, ELI AND PAIGE.
IT'S K.D., CELTICS BANNER AND
JAMES HARDEN BEARD.
PAGE IS ABOUT SIX BLOCKS AWAY
FROM THE DENTIST, ELI IS IN THE
BACK ENJOYING THE PURPLE AND
GOLD.
THE LAST TWO PLAYED TO YOU AND
YOUR SENSIBILITIES.
PAIGE PLAYED TO ME.
>> I KNOW YOU'RE ROCKING WITH
PAIGE.
>> AS A TAKE MASTER JUDGE, THERE
CAN ONLY BE ONE.
IT'S LIKE HIGHLANDER, ONLY ONE
T"TAKE MASTERS."
>> I HAVE TO GIVE IT TO PAIGE.
SHE CAME THROUGH WITH THE
EDITING.
SHE BROUGHT IT TO ANOTHER LEVEL.
>> LET'S BRING HER BACK ON HERE,
ON HER WAY TO THE DDS.
IT'S OUR RESPONSIBILITY TO
ANNOUNCE PAGE IS THE BEST.
THIS IS YOUR CHANCE.
YOUR ACCEPTANCE SPEECH.
YOU'RE OFFICIALLY A TAKE MASTER.
HOW DOES IT FEEL?
>> IT'S MY FIRST TIME, SO WHAT A
GREAT EXPERIENCE.
THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME.
SO MUCH FUN.
CAN'T WAIT TO SUBMIT MY NEXT HOT
TAKE.
>> PAIGE, YOU GUYS MUST HAVE
GOOD WIFI.
>> 5G.
>> I GOT THE 5G, OF COURSE.
>> PAGE, THE ONE THING WE'LL ASK
YOU IS WHILE THE DENTIST IS
WORKING, YOU NEED TO TELL HIM
THAT YOU -- OR HER, THAT YOU WON
"TAKE MASTERS," BUT YOU CANNOT
EXPLAIN WHAT IT MEANS.
YOU JUST GO I'M A "TAKE MASTER"
AND DON'T TALK.
>> OKAY.
I WILL.
I PROMISE.
>> CONGRATULATIONS.
>> THANK YOU, SO MUCH.
>> A BIG CONGRATULATIONS TO ELI
AND KENDALL FOR EARNING MORE PAT
BEVERLIES AFTER THEIR TAKES.
WE'LL TAKE -- ELI, KENDALL, YOU
GUYS WERE GREAT.
SUBMIT TAKES NEXT TIME AS WELL.
>> LAKERS TAKES WILL GET THE
WIN.
ANYTHING PRO LeBRON, PRO
SAVANNAH.
PRO ZURI, PRO BRYCE.
>> LOOK OUT FOR TWITTER AND
INSTAGRAM.
WE DON'T KNOW WHAT IT WILL BE
NEXT TIME.
COULD BE NFL, NBA, ANYTHING IN
GENERAL.
THE NEXT TIME WE THROW OUT THE
TAKE SIGNAL, 20 SECONDS, DM IT
TWO "BLEACHER REPORT" ON TWITTER
AND IG.
YOU'LL HAVE A CHANCE TO COME ON
AND WE'LL SEND THEM SOME SWAG
FOR JOINING US.
"TAKE MASTERS," THE SECOND
CHAMPION HAS BEEN CROWNED.
>> ARE THEY ALL GOING TO MEET UP
PREFERABLY IN THE BAHAMAS OR
HAWAII?
SO WE CAN ALL DO IT LIVE.
TURN UP.
I DON'T THINK I TOLD THE PEOPLE
BUT I'M ALMOST DELTA GOLD
STATUS.
TRYING TO GET TO PLATINUM.
DIAMOND I HEARD IS THE BEST.
TRYING TO GET THAT GOING.
SEND THOSE TAKES.
WE WON'T ROAST YOU GUYS.
20 SECONDS OR LESS.
WE'RE VERY, VERY FRIENDLY WITH
THE TAKES WE GET.
THERE'S NO SLANDER REALLY.
UNLESS YOU SAY SOME ABSURD OFF
THE WALL STUFF.
SEND THEM IN.
APPRECIATE YOU.
THIS IS ENJOYABLE.
>> ZAVIAN, THE OFFER STILL
STANDS.
$50 FOR YOU TO SEND IN A
20-SECOND TAKE THE NEXT TIME WE
DO "TAKE MASTERS."
IF YOU DON'T DO IT, EVERYONE IN
THE COMMENTS SECTION KNOWS
YOU'RE AFRAID AND YOU DON'T WANT
TO FALL ASLEEP THINKING ABOUT
THAT, DO YOU?
YOU DON'T.
FOR KING JOSIAH, I'M ADAM
LEFKOE.
THIS IS "TAKE MASTERS."
BE ON THE LOOKOUT.
WE NEED YOUR TAKES.
HAVE A GOOD DAY, EVERYBODY.
♪